Oh, bisschen groß, die Emotes.
Exzellent Stream.
Exzellent, er ist mal im Weinkeller gewesen.
Habt, ich hab euch ja gestern mal ein Weinkeller im Stream gezeigt.
Exzellent Weinkeller.
Äh, mal kurz mein Mikrofon rausziehen.
Mal kurz das Mikrofon rausziehen.
Da stimmt irgendwas net.
Exzellent Mikrofon, jetzt stimmt wieder alles, sehr gut.
Ähm, hat Twitch gecheckt, dass wir online sind.
Ich hoffe mal, ja angeblich, angeblich hat das alles klar.
Stats, ähm, keine Frametrops, das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Exzellent, Leute, ich hab den, ich zeig euch jetzt gleich den, den big brainigsten Windows Hack, den ihr seit langem gesehen habt.
Gleich, gleich weil mehr Leute da sind.
Der ist, der ist Poggers, Pog, Pogchamp und, äh, Fivehead zusammen.
Was soll ich euch gleich zeigen, der ist, der ist wahrlich exzellent.
Zeige ich euch, aber vorher zeige ich euch nochmal was anderes, und zwar Chat, ich seh euch kurz nicht, ich muss refreshen.
Ah, hallo an alle, die schon da sind, ich hab gerade den Chatref recht, ich hab gesehen, es haben schon ein paar Leute reingeschrieben.
Schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid.
Ähm, passt die Lautstärke? Ah, Ticken, Tickenleiser können wir noch machen.
Ein Tickenleiser.
So.
Ja gut, das muss ich jetzt erst mal anfangen, woop woop zu machen.
Also, passt mal auf Leute, ich hab was gemacht.
Ähm, ich hab was gemacht, das gehört sich eigentlich nicht.
Also sowohl als Gamer, als auch als Informatiker.
Passt das, passt das nicht, ja.
Und zwar war ich vorhin unterm Wasser.
Im Bad.
Und ich hab hier meinen Dashboard mit der Heizung.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal zusammen an.
Das ist nämlich das quasi, das was wir gestern und vorvorgestern im Stream gebaut haben.
Jetzt fertig.
Und guckt euch mal mein schönes Heizung, ähm, Handy Games, oh ne ne, so tief bin ich auch noch nicht gesunken.
Guckt euch mal mein schönes Dashboard an, für die Heizung.
Ist das nicht next level exquisite?
Man sieht die Wassertemperatur.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, wann ich duschen gewesen bin.
Roll mal lieber das Windows aus wozu.
Das stört das nicht, dass es ein paar Icons auf dem Desktop hat.
Was meint ihr, wo ich duschen gewesen bin?
Man sieht es, man kommt gar nicht drauf, ja.
Natürlich hier.
Also sprich, die Temperatur ist runtergegangen, bis auf 16,4 Grad.
So um 17.43 Uhr oder so.
Im gleichen Maß ist der Brenner wie verrückt an und aus gegangen.
Und zur gleichen Zeit sind glaube ich die Abgas, die Temperatur von den Abgasen ist raufgegangen.
Auf irgendwie an die 70 Grad.
Also das hat, das hat wirklich volle Pulle.
Hast du das gebaut? Das Dashboard. Das Dashboard an sich ist Grafana, aber die Auswertung habe ich gebaut.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Raspberry Pi an die Heizung angeschlossen, was drauf installiert.
Custom Software, die da draußen Prometheus Exporter macht und dann Prometheus in Grafana rein.
Aber hier sieht man schon, funktioniert wunderbar.
Die Pumpe hat in der ganzen Zeit nicht gepumpt.
Witzigerweise. Ich glaube auch, ich glaube entweder, dass die Heizung zu schwach für das ganze Haus ist, aber es kann ja nicht sein, einfach beim Duschen.
Ich glaube das Ding ist irgendwie fail konfiguriert, weil ich würde eigentlich erwarten, dass wenn ich dusche, dass der Brenner einfach volle Pulle brennt.
Für Viertelstunde oder so.
Ich muss mir gerade mal was aufschreiben, sonst vergesse ich das wieder.
Ups.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So sieht's aus. Aber damit beschäftigen wir uns heute nicht.
Ich wollte euch bloß mal zeigen, wie schön das Ganze funktioniert.
Man kann ja auch umstellen, zum Beispiel letzten 15 Minuten sieht man das oder die letzten drei Stunden.
Also es ist eindeutig, wo ich mich unter das Wasser gestellt habe, oder?
Vorher alles normal und dann.
Und dann, als ich hier fertig war.
Gucken wir mal, wie lange ich unter dem Wasser war. Ich würde mal sagen, hier so ungefähr hat es angefangen.
Bis, äh, wahrscheinlich bis so da, bis es wieder hoch geht.
Wie lange habe ich unter dem Wasser gestanden? Irgendwie eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten oder so. Es kommt ungefähr hin.
Ja.
Exzellent.
Das sollte aber auf jeden Fall nicht so sein.
Das Kleingeschrie- Oh ja, da hast du recht.
Das, das, das müssen wir fixen. Ähm, Sign in.
Das müssen wir tatsächlich fixen. Das gefällt mir auch nicht.
Äh, Moment, wo war das nochmal? Hier. Fock.
Ah, yes. Exquisite, exquisite.
Safe.
Ah, jetzt muss ich das Dashboard neu exportieren in, oder? Ist der Hashtag der gleiche geblieben?
Ich hoffe mal. So, zumindest, ähm, die Sache gucken wir uns heute nicht näher an.
Ich wollte euch bloß noch mal zeigen, dass das wunderbar funktioniert, was wir da so die letzten Male gebastelt haben.
Ich muss mal mein Kabel ein bisschen entfüllen.
So. Also, ne, seht ihr, das funktioniert richtig gut.
Hast du schon das Path of Exile Leak Announcement gesehen? Nee.
Wo ich eben geguckt habe, vor einer Stunde war noch nichts da. Echt?
Wo?
Hast du mal einen Link? Wo, wo, wo ist das? Ich mein, irgendwo hier muss das ja drinne stehen.
Mega Leak.
Also, dann mal gucken.
Official Trail? Oh, das müssen wir uns, das müssen wir uns kurz mal angucken.
Moment, das ist doch gar nicht, das ist doch, das ist aber nichts Offizielles, ne?
Das, oder, ist das irgendein Leak? Oder wie? Weil das ist nicht die offizielle Path of Exile, das ist irgendein Fake, oder?
Das ist doch irgendein Fake. Das wollte ich mir mal kurz angucken, dann fangen wir an mit der Windows-Geschichte als alter Path of Exile Grinder.
Oh, das sieht legit aus, das sieht legit aus, das sieht nicht, äh, zusammengefaked hat.
Äh, es ist nebelig, es ist nebelig, es ruckelt, das Spiel ruckelt noch nicht genug.
Ne, das ist die neue Path of Exile Leak. Gibt's ja alle drei Monate, gibt's was neues immer.
Also, okay, es ist nebelig, das erkenne ich schon mal.
Oh, Moment, was war das doch gerade?
What?
Add 6 per, ohhhh.
Kann man die Skills jetzt selbst auswählen?
Was ist an dem Game so gut? Das ist das beste Action-RPG, was es gibt zurzeit. Man kann Diablo 3 einpacken.
Aha, das sieht ziemlich OP aus.
Ah, wenn man das sockelt, kriegt man quasi einen Addon auf seinem Skilltree irgendwie. Oh, das ist, das ist cool. Oh, das gibt, es ist ja nicht so, als hätte Path of Exile nicht eh schon 30 Billiarden Varianten, was man spielen kann. Jetzt sind es halt 50 Billiarden Varianten.
Oh, das ist nice. Ich spiele aber eh wieder Noob-Summoner-Klasse, wenn sie das nicht nerven, da brauch ich das alles nicht.
Okay, den Kram gibt es immer noch. Oder er ist jetzt wieder neu.
Moin, Doki. Ah, Doki, ich muss dir was zeigen, wenn du gerade da bist.
Heizung, alles ist hier huge eingerichtet.
Oh, das sieht cool aus. Developer-Commentary-Artner.
Das ist so eine neue Rift-Geschichte oder sowas in der Richtung.
Also ein bisschen wie diese, diese, diese, diese, diese roten Portale, die es schon gibt.
Oh, das ist cool. Oh, das ist cool. Das heißt, das ist im Prinzip einfach Content mal 2 im Endeffekt, weil man kann alles bisherige spielen mit dem neuen Mod. Das ist nice.
Wie weit bist du mit dem Heizungs-Dashboard? Das habe ich euch gerade schon gezeigt, aber ihr wart nicht beschrieben. Ich zeige das gleich nochmal.
Der Endgame ist Serious nicht mehr der letzte jetzt. Der Serious-Fight ist easy as fuck als Summoner.
Das sieht sehr nice aus. Wann geht die League los? Ich brauche das Startdatum, da wird gegrindet, da wird der Hardcore-Grind gemacht.
Oh, also noch 14 Tage, nein ein bisschen länger. 3 Wochen. Da sind wir dabei, da sind wir dabei. Genau, also hier, Heizungs-Dashboard.
Alles schon eingerichtet, funktioniert mittlerweile. Eine Sache, die sehr merkwürdig ist, man sieht es, ich muss gerade die Sache ein bisschen erweitern auf 3 Stunden.
Also ich habe hier die Soll-Temperatur vom Wasser, die aktuelle Wassertemperatur, ob das Ding einen Fehler meldet, was der Brenner so macht und die Abgastemperatur und auf wie viel Prozent die Pumpe läuft.
Was natürlich sehr merkwürdig ist, vielleicht kann Herr Doxy was dazu sagen, wenn er die Dinge einbaut. Hier bin ich, hier habe ich unter dem Wasser gestanden.
Hier war ich unter der Dusche und das warme Wasser ist übelst getroppt in der Zeit und zeitgleich, man sieht jetzt leider, ich habe den Graph hier ein bisschen verkackt, zeitgleich, das ist ungefähr hier so, zeitgleich ist der Brenner wie verrückt am An- und Ausgehen.
Also ich hätte jetzt hier eigentlich erwartet, wenn ich warm Wasser quasi aus der, ja, entnehme, ja, jaja.
Wenn ich warm Wasser entnehme, hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass der volle Pulle läuft oder halt durchgängig läuft, macht er aber nicht.
Gucken, ob wir das verschieben können, dann sieht man es besser.
Ich habe halt gedacht, Brennerstatistik juckt nicht so sehr.
Guck, zu der Zeit, jetzt sieht man es ja gut, zu der Zeit, ich schiebe mal die Abgaswerte unten drunter.
Zu der Zeit, wo ich hier duschen gewesen bin, ist der Brenner ist übelst an-aus, an-aus, an-aus, an-aus gegangen, die ganze Zeit, aber die Abgaswerte waren auch so nicht so hoch an der Zeit.
Der Brenner macht das gerade auch, ja, vorher hat er das nicht gemacht, vorher hat er durchgängig 32% gemacht, die ganze Zeit.
Ich hätte eigentlich erwartet, wenn ich mich unter die Dusche stelle und warm Wasser anmache, dann gibt er Gas.
War die Einrichtung vom Heizungsstöcker kompliziert, du kannst dir einfach die letzten zwei Streams angucken, da sieht man es.
Das ist die Temperatur, 47 Grad, das ist definitiv die Temperatur.
Ich zeige das mal meinem Heizungsmann, ich habe jetzt ja die ganze Statistik gelockt.
Ich habe ja die ganze Statistik da, das zeige ich dir mal und dann kann er sich ja überlegen, was er dazu sagt.
So Leute, aber heute machen wir was anderes und ich habe euch gesagt, ich zeige euch den krassesten Windows Hack aller Zeiten, also Sixhead Wine Premium Extrem.
Also mehr geht nicht. Kennt ihr das? Ihr wollt beispielsweise eine Windows ISO runterladen, weil ihr jetzt ein Windows installieren wollt.
Das mussten wir nämlich jetzt machen, weil ich wäre diese alternativen Desktops für Windows, die wäre ich garantiert nicht auf meinem richtigen Windows installieren.
Das machen wir jetzt schön in der VM.
Siehst du das mit einem extra Stecker und einem extra Programm oder kann man theoretisch für alle Heizungen machen?
Also das, was ich habe, geht nur für Wiesmann, es gibt bestimmt für die meisten Heizungen andere Sachen.
Ich habe so ein Ding gekauft, das ist so ein Wiesmann Stecker auf USB und da hinten ist ein Raspberry Pi dran mit einer Software von GitHub, die Leute das Wiesmann Zeug nachprogrammiert haben.
Und da funktioniert es auf Anhieb. Was ich dazu gebaut habe ist, ich habe quasi um diese Software noch einen Prometheus Exporter rumgestrickt, dass ich das Ganze in Grafana kriege.
Den haben wir gestern programmiert und eingerichtet und ich glaube zwei Streams vorher haben wir auf dem Raspberry Pi die Heizung eingerichtet.
Also wenn es dich interessiert, kannst du einfach die letzten zwei Streams gucken, wo es um die Sache ging.
Prometheus ist ein Tool, was Statistiken und Metriken sammelt und im Prinzip ist Grafana nur die Oberfläche, die das Ganze anzeigt.
Zum Beispiel, ich habe hier Prometheus exportiert bei mir, hier Vito Dens, diese Sachen exportiert das, das ist halt was mein Programm macht im Endeffekt, diese Sachen zu exportieren.
Das Tool auf GitHub hat keine grafische Oberfläche. Moment, das Tool von dem ich auf GitHub rede ist das hier.
Das ist nur dafür da, das Wiesmann-Protokoll zu verstehen. Achso, wieviel ich brauche, habe ich nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Ich kann dir aber sagen, was es ist. Es ist eine Vito Dens 222 steht drauf. Was ich verbrauche, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nur nachgeguckt, was ich für eine Einzung habe. Aber irgendwas kann da nicht stimmen. Das Verhalten ist irgendwie sehr sehr viel.
Genau das Ding ist das, was das Wiesmann-Protokoll kann. Mit dem, was ich verbrauche, muss ich mal gucken. Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht auf die Schnelle gefunden.
Das ist das Programm, was dieses Wiesmann-Protokoll auf dem Raspberry Pi kapiert. Mein Programm geht an diesen V-Control D und liest die Werte aus.
Exportiert das als Prometheus-Metriken und Prometheus lese ich dann im Grafana ein. Die Abgastemperaturen sind auch so hoch.
Ich werde es dir mal zeigen. Das Gute ist, dass ich jetzt die Statistiken dazu habe. Und das kann ich ihm einfach zeigen.
Guck mal hier, wenn ich duschen gehe.
Das ist das Programm.
Wie kann man das jetzt machen, dass der Docker-Container die Settings beibehält? Du musst ein Volume angeben.
Du stellst in deinem Docker-Compose-Fall ein Volume und sagst welcher lokaler Ordner, wo quasi im Container gemountet werden soll.
Da steht bei jeweiligen Containern dabei, welcher Ort das sein muss im Container.
Also das ist alles andere als...
Gut, also fangen wir jetzt mal an. Ich wollte euch ja den krassesten Windows-Hack aller Zeiten zeigen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man hier sowas ausprobieren will.
Wenn man eine alternative Oberfläche für Windows und das nicht auf seinem Windows machen will, installiert man sich in der Regel eine VM.
Und um eine VM zu installieren, braucht man ein Windows-ISO. Das Problem ist, wenn man ein Windows-ISO runterladen will bei Microsoft, dann geht das nicht.
Da muss man sich das Media-Creation-Tool runterladen. Und dann kann man das lokal erstellen. Aber jetzt passt mal auf.
Fadilkini, zwei Monate. Danke schön.
So, was man einfach machen muss, ist entweder den User-Agent umstellen auf Mac, auf Safari. Aber es geht viel einfacher.
Ihr macht die Developer-Tools auf und stellt einfach auf Mobile-Device um.
Und dann refrescht ihr die Seite und schon könnt ihr runterladen.
Ist das nicht nice?
Das ist doch mal hier Elevenhead.
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter hassen diesen Trick.
Microsoft-Mitarbeiter hassin den Trick.
ist user-friendly das tool naja einfach runterladen finde ich ehrlich gesagt
user-friendlier als so ein komisches tool installieren zu müssen
so wir müssen jetzt noch drei minuten warten kann ich mal gucken ob ich im chat
media creation tool läuft nur als ansaft ich habe schon lange kein media creation tool
mehr gestartet
da haben wir ein eigenes kommando für ich glaube ausrufe zeichen 1 oder so ich
probiere es mal aus da habe ich das mal erklärt warum ich da so mein copy paste
kamo mit eins so ich gucke jetzt mal den chat durch während das runterlädt
moment wo macht man den chrome noch mal den download auf hier na
exzellent gucken wir mal den download an
man kann auch die iso direkt runterladen ja aber jetzt haben wir es ja ich weiß
nicht warum man das trick 17 verbraucht aber ihr müsst schon zugeben der trick
ist schon ist schon ziemlich ziemlich gut
ja also doch ich werde das mal meinem heizungs mann erzählen der soll sich
das einfach mal angucken und da sein kommentar zu abgeben du fühlst dich
verarscht von microsoft wieso weil du immer das mit dem media creation tool
machst viel glück woher kommst du aus hanau glaube ich nicht dass du das bist
oh stimmt wir haben jetzt an den wendler den wendler flick als im oder die kardo flick ist out wendler flick ist in wo das ist
hanau ist da was vor letzte woche also bei frankfurter ist da wo der typ amok
gelaufen ist vor ein paar tagen und gestern in der nähe in kassel in der
nähe in hessen auch der typ in den carnavals umzug gefahren ist oder scam
train leute 94 prozent hype train oh mein gott der hype train huge gibt twitch
alle euer geld auch liebevoll genannt der scam train skam ars train
und wenn ihr mich jetzt habt kriegt ihr zugriff auf sagenhafte vier in worten
vier emotes von 24 möglichen emotes ganze vier ich muss mich echt mal bei der
gelegenheit muss ich das ja immer einmal ich muss mich echt langsam mal wieder
auf neu emotes kümmern wie gesagt wir haben 20 emotes slots noch frei und wenn
man schon gesagt hat dann bist du eh in der abo falle da ist dann ist vorbei
hier bin aus zehn ok installation ist durch so dann dann dann dann legen wir
mal wenn aus zehn vor allem an und probieren den ganzen mist mal aus custom
workstation ich installiere selbst windows 10 jawohl next next vier kerne
next windows braucht das 4096 ram windows windows braucht ordentlich ram natt
jawohl excellent excellent excellent 60 g 40 g komm windows mit 40 g auskommen
oder was meint ihr 40 g könnte knapp werden finish soll mal schnell noch mal
schnell den drucker entfernen drucker wo ist der drucker der muss weg und die
soundkarte machen wir na mal gucken vielleicht lassen wir die dran
accelerate 3d graphics blablabla auf geht's was
satan 0 ich habe die vm gerade angelegt was hat er denn jetzt schon wieder für
schmerzen ach so ja weil ich use physical drive welches welches physical
drive ich habe ich habe nicht mal ein cd laufwerk dran ok mal gucken ob unser
windows 10 iso funktioniert ist performante als virtual box ich glaube
das nimmt sich nicht so viel ich finde vor allem aber insgesamt deutlich
angenehmer sich attached so noch mal neu starten
so jetzt müssen wir uns erst mal die big brain windows installation geben
da kommen jetzt nicht drum herum also erst mal erst mal im schnelldurchgang
windows language to install currencies ne ne ne time and currency machen wir schon auf
deutsch sonst haben wir die ganzen kokona einheiten
drinnen das wollen wir garantiert nicht da war dann btu und fahrenheit und
solche komischen dinger
aber bitte pro natürlich pro was sonst kann man das noch auswählen
i don't have a product key
ah hier pro natürlich windows 10 pro von pros für pros
windows bräuchte man life usb stick ja tatsächlich ich hatte mal den windows
p in windows px e boot windows rescue system px e boot habe ich aber nie
benutzt und dementsprechend ist es komplett outdated ich glaube läuft gar
nicht mehr upgrade custom install next jetzt installierter kram
heute der hype train 15 sekunden noch und keiner ist keiner hat den scam train mit
gemacht was ist mit euch los der chat wenn man sich auf den twitch chat
verlässt ist man echt echt verlassen
der scam train er überließt mich auch was echt
ich überlesen
wo denn
ach so ich drücke die daumen mit einem klemper wenn da so eine alter kommt sind
die meist mit der neuen technik überfordert genervt wenn das alles
läuft ja dann hat er pech ich kann mit meiner heizung locken was er will was ich
will ne so schlimm sind die nicht cute chat ist zu big brain für den scam train
ja ich glaube mit dem kann man reden und wenn nicht ganz ehrlich es gibt ja
noch andere
irgendjemand hat was gefragt mit virtual box eben also quatsch mit source hat
noch was gefragt hast du schon als video in dem du dein linux so einiges
videos benutzt erstellt oder machst du das noch wir machen das im live stream
fertig wir hatten ja mal angefangen
hat der pfeiffer typ schon klar das haben wir uns auch sogar schon mal
angeguckt im stream also zu der frage die mich finden sie leider nicht mehr zu
der frage mit virtual box oder vmw ich glaube performance mäßig ist es nicht
so ein großer unterschied ich denke aber dass vmw vom unterbau her und von den
features moderner ist virtual box ist so auf sparflamme bei oracle zumindest hat
man so den eindruck und virtual box ist halt vom user interface und von da wie
sagt man so schön von der user experience halt deutlich nicer als
virtual box das ist auch der grund warum ich vmw habe also workstation nicht
player player gibt es auch noch aber ich finde von der workstation tatsächlich
mal was oder preis zumindest wenn man sich an weihnachten immer in ihrem sale
kauft schon gerechtfertigt ist auch nie leute fuck wisst ihr was jetzt kommt
kottana jetzt kommt gleich kottana gleich gleich kommt kottana ich ziehe
kottana einfach die soundkarte raus gleich sollte kottana anfangen zu
schwätzen ziehe ich ziehe ich die soundkarte
raus
kio kun mir ist es ein rätsel wie du in dieser aussage jetzt irgendwas in dieser
richtung erkannt hast
just a moment
also wir haben zur auswahl die musik kann sich heute nicht entscheiden ob sie
lauter laut oder leise sein will
ich war noch ein stückchen lager ist immer gerade zu laut
also was wir heute ausprobieren wenn kottana da in senf abgelassen ist also ich
will ein paar sachen ausprobieren es gibt verschiedene varianten es gibt einmal
hier mit kairos shell so was habe ich letztens ein video zugesehen
das ersetzt komplett alles unter windows an oberfläche also sprich den desktop
den die startleiste und den explorer also das sieht das sieht komplett anders
aus wie geht es der katz der geht es gut
die lich habe ich ein bild eigentlich von da von da habe ich hier gar ich habe
hier gar keinen aber ich habe hier ein bild da da ist er der geht es gut
also das ersetzt alles bei windows dann habe ich das jemand ausprobieren das ist
ein ein teiling window manager für windows verwende unter liegungs auch nur
teilen window manager da habe ich allerdings nicht so große hoffnungen
drinne weil das ist eben den auto hotkey script mal gucken ob das so funktioniert
probieren wir dann noch aus und als letztes will ich mir mal die
aktuelle entwicklung angucken oder keine ahnung welche reinfolgen wir das machen
von open shell open shell ist quasi nur ein alternatives startmenü aber als
erstes und hier bin ich wirklich mal gespannt drauf probieren wir das ding hier
aus für was den kompletten den kompletten windows desktop austauscht
oh region ist korrekt germany jess
ist es right keyboard no mein richtiges kann man da einstippen
mehr german im moment leute habe ich habe ich eben gerade ausversehen die
sprache umgestellt kann das sein ne oder ich hoffe nicht
ich will die sprache auf englisch lassen ich will das ganze ding auf englisch
lassen und bloß die tastatur auf deutsch wisst ihr noch was das letzte
mal für einen riesen akt war englisches windows und deutsche tastatur gucken ob
das jetzt einfacher geht als letztes mal
excellent
just a moment die ofter kram neu startet und macht und tut alter
now let's see what's new for from windows eigentlich will ich das überhaupt nicht
sehen ok set up for personal jetzt kommt drauf an jetzt wollen sie uns gleich den
microsoft account aufschwätzen jetzt wollen uns gleich so offline account das
ist so richtig versteckt limited experience und jetzt darf man und jetzt
darf man sich den lokalen account anlegen tests next 123456
oh even better online account ich weiß nicht welche doch in der pro version
chill free ist hier noch ist da noch dabei ich verstehe nicht warum warum ein
offline account eine limited experience ist security question kann man das
überspringen
1 1 1 1 1 perfekt
nein no no no no no basic das ist toll send diagnostic data zu
microsoft ich kann entweder auswählen voll oder basic oft gibt es nicht oft
existiert von microsoft nicht ich möchte nichts an microsoft schicken
steht nicht zur diskussion basic no no no was für eine scheiße oder bei
enterprise gibt es ok ich habe noch nie in enterprise installieren ich hoffe ich
komme auch drumherum everything ready for you ich bin ja schon
ganz aufgeregt
this may take several minutes das ist jibayt das dauert zehn sekunden
oder so wo ist cortana anscheinend bei der installation nicht mehr dabei
du kannst das gibt mit control alt quatsch ernsthaft warum warum sollte ich
mit control alt entfernen skippen können echt dann ist alles auf default und die
fault ist bestimmt an
probieren wir jetzt nicht aus
guck mal seht ihr wie der bildschirm hin und her wackelt dass es so aussieht
als macht er was almost sehr ah ja welcome to your microsoft edge start
page ja edge brauchen wir nicht gut das erste was wir jetzt machen müssten ist
forever tools installieren und dann geht's los install forever tools
weg immer tools yes watsch machen wir aus
ab hallo weiter drücken weiter typical install so da müssen wir restarten und
dann sollte es im fullscreen alles funktionieren
und dann muss man noch chrome installieren oder firefox oder meinetwegen
wenn ihr wollt auch den neuen chrome edge neuen spiel gerade was für den
browser nehmen war firefox chrome chromium chrome edge
brave opera gaming
nein wir nehmen nicht opera gaming chat wir waldi wir nehmen wir waldi das
finde ich gute vorschlag das finde ich einen guten vorschlag wir nehmen wir
waldi waldi taugt so da sind wir links das einzige wozu man microsoft edge
braucht die waldi downloaden
mach noch einen snapshot von der vm oh ja gut dass du dran denkst gut dass du
dran denkst ich installiere noch den browser dann mach ich
snapshot
default hat wie waldi den adblocker defaultmäßig dabei weißt das jemand
oder muss ich erst noch ublog installieren
das ist mal next level auf bing suchen wir nach google ok ublog origin aber
wir können einfach den chrome den chrome blog excellent ok ich habe den knopf
getroffen sehr gut nice aiming skills sehr schön soll jetzt
machen snapshot von der vm weil wir müssen das ding bestimmt noch öfters
zurücksetzen dass sowas immer noch unter windows 10 an fehlern auftritt ist
komisch nach und transparent das ding ok also github github kairo shell dann bin
ich mal gespannt hardware beschleunigung deaktivieren das kann ja das wird
wahrscheinlich daran liegen
wie hast du mal ausprobiert krieg wie windows 10 besser läuft mit hardware
acceleration oder ohne ich würde sagen pauschal eigentlich mit aber so
wirklich sicher bin ich mir da nicht
wäre mit opera gaming sicherlich passiert ist es halt auch ein chrome
wahrscheinlich wir genau das gleiche passieren zur installer
prerelease vor vier tagen leute sind für sind für mutig installieren die
aktuelle beta oder wenn wenn schon dann richtig
snapshot snapshot läuft snapshot läuft ja state saving leading edge or go home
so sehe ich das auch so jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt jetzt bin ich echt mal
gespannt ja ja wir führen alles aus
welcome to kairo installer hier machen wir den kram zu excellent next so was
haben wir jetzt zur auswahl run and start up advanced user only replace
explorer run kairo instead of windows explorer notice also deshalb many new
features in windows wollen wir gleich die komplette das komplett program
machen oder erst mal nur nur die basic variante installieren
go for it ok volle pulle install
das ok das ging jetzt relativ easy die startleiste ist noch da ich sehe sie
doch ah jetzt ist die startleiste weg
aha ok
das ist doch der ganz normale windows explorer ach stimmt ich vergesse ja
immer dass der windows explorer sowohl die shell ist als auch der datei manager
so es sieht ein bisschen mech style aus
es sieht ein bisschen mech style aus muss ich sagen
wie startet man jetzt hier was
was passiert eigentlich wenn ich exit kairo mache
an den starten windows wieder ok gut ok das ist schon mal ganz gut
check was haben wir hier desktop
ok wir starten einen browser das ist ein nice feature dass das gefällt mir
guckt mal man kann wenn man das fenster vollbild hat den desktop overlayen und
dann da sachen drin starten das ist doch cool dass das gefällt mir
echt ganz gut das ist mal ein sinnvoll ein sinnvolles feature wer hat schon
vernünftige verknüpfung auf dem desktop ich excellent verknüpfung habe ich auf
dem desktop die allerbesten verknüpfungen überhaupt
vor allem habe ich dreimal keq in unterschiedlichen abwandlungen das ist
unglaublich wichtig dass man keq in 50 varianten auf dem desktop hat
die klein kann man eigentlich wenn aus des top machen also excellent
warum kann windows transparenz in eikens aber ab einer gewissen vergrößerung
nicht mehr seht ihr das ab einer gewissen vergrößerung geht die
transparenz in windows eikens nicht mehr
und dort geht die transparenz und beim anderen nicht mein gott ist das
finners kram kaputt bei dem geht sie nicht bei den anderen geht sie dann
guckt euch mal an total kaputt
das ist massiv keq
direkt in kairo test ich weiß noch nicht mal wie ich dort überhaupt eikens
wie komme ich denn hier auf dem desktop so okay man kann schon mal keine
desktop eikens verschieben anscheinend desktop
was was macht das gedürzt wo wie was ist das
wo sind das mal multiple desktops kann das sein
ach das ist der folder den er auf dem desktop anzeigt ach so okay das ist echt
unnötig und jetzt kann man die folder hier die die die ordner hier also man
kann tatsächlich mehrere desktop ordner haben das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
blöd allerdings hätte ich viel lieber virtuelle virtuelle desktops
viel lieber virtuelle desktops
was haben wir jetzt noch documents nix drin downloads gut naja places documents
häh ach so da ist nix drin ach moment das ist da time manager das ist da
time manager und browser in einem das ist ein bisschen wie dieses startmenü
davon meck von mac os ok da muss man sich da muss man sich tatsächlich echt
dran gewöhnen ich ich ich weiß nicht ob ich damit klarkomme
so was kann das ding sonst noch desktop search lull
okay das ist die ganz normale windows suche
okay das ist der kram also ich kann jetzt zum beispiel so nach settings
das ist quasi die ganz normale aber man kann man kann nichts auswählen
guckt settings da muss ich maus klicken ich kann nicht hoch und runter gehen
das wirkt ein bisschen unfertig ehrlich gesagt
und das ist halt das ganz normale windows zeug ok das sind das im prinzip
shortcuts zu ordnen da kann man da kann man nicht allzu viel machen
so kann das ding task view ok das ist die übersicht über meine
task new desktop wie ah guckt mal es gehen doch
multiple desktops
es gehen doch multiple desktops
aber die taskleiste ist kaputt die taskleiste ist kaputt die taskleiste
zeigt weiterhin die sachen vom ersten desktop an ok vielleicht vielleicht ist
es auch absicht vielleicht ist es auch absicht
aber ich finde das ziemlich gewöhnungsbedürftig ich mein guck mal
ich sehe überhaupt nicht auf welchem desktop ich bin wenn ich jetzt da drauf
klicke geht auf den ersten und da geht er auf den zweiten dass er pflicht da
wirst du verrückt im kopf da gefällt mir das standardmäßig
schon besser dass du hier nur das siehst was quasi auf dem jeweiligen desktop
offen ist also das ding ansonsten ansonsten mehr mehr scheint das nicht
zu sein das ist glaube ich schon mehr oder
weniger alles ich gibt dieses notification fenster
gehst du fort dieses notification fenster verwendet keine sau
man kann lauter und leiser machen ja da hätte ich mit gerechnet und das
sind die normalen die normalen settings ok das braucht echt kein mensch das
braucht wirklich kein mensch das ding das erscheint mir huge huge überflüssig
und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen besser als die normale oberfläche finde ich
nicht ich meine nur weil es von der leiste in ticken
woops ein ticken nach meck aussieht ist halt keinerlei der funktionalität
vorhanden
ja vom style her wird mich das gar nicht mal großartig stören aber von dem
funktionsumfang her überzeugt mich das nicht wirklich
okay mal gucken was sie sagen was sie alles haben wir müssen mal die
features ausprobieren customizable ok wo ist das wo ist das
customizable wie kann wie kann ich es customisem ok kairos settings
language englisch restart wir gucken uns die settings noch mal an
about ist das denn das ist definitiv keine also wie diese fenster hier
aussehen ist das keine native native windows geschichte oder mal gucken ob
wir rauskriegen und wieder kram programmiert ist mit was
doch uwp oder ist das uwp
scheint mir scheint mir uwp zeug zu sein oder nicht uwp wahrscheinlich
wpf zeugs was kann man sonst noch einstellen kairos settings haben wir
mal gucken wir mal also also das ist auf jeden fall native windows so eklig wie
das hier aussieht wahrscheinlich sogar in windows all das windows forms oder so
fast es ist auf jeden fall zu klein kann man die schrift größer machen
flat moment white default was ich sehe da überhaupt kein unterschied
ah doch ja flets sieht besser aus menü bar guck mal die windows leiste die
wenn man windows taste drückt kommt die windows leiste so rüber nur ohne nur
komplett ohne taskbar ok so wirklich gut rein passen tut das ganze nicht
echt bin ich zu laut
bin ich zu nähe ich bin so laut wie immer
ich bin so laut wie immer ich habe irgendwo auch mein mein kompressor
drin dass ich gar nicht nicht zu laut nicht zu laut sein kann
jubatet ju gatt was was ist das show notification eigens
always warum muss ich eigentlich für alles kairos starten alle für alles umfassende
starten
ach hier oben ist die notification ach so jetzt erkenne ich das excellent so was
kann man sonst noch schönes einstellen blue behind menü bar
aber muss alles neu starten warum warum muss man alles neu starten
ist es jetzt blau ist es jetzt blauer als vorher irgendwie ich erkenne keinen
unterschied zu vorher
enable kairou menü hotkey was win schift z ach so alles brauche man eher nicht
ach blöhr ach blöhr nicht blu blöhr behind menü bar es ist nicht eingeschaltet
wahrscheinlich weil es eine vm ist das sieht man wahrscheinlich in der vm nicht
show menü bar und mit multiple monitors ne geh weg ich will ihn neu starten
desktop enable desktop will ich nicht ausschalten
eigen size large
man kann die schriftgröße nicht einstellen das enttäuscht mich ein
bisschen weil die schriftgröße mehr für mich eine wichtige geschichte weil ich
sehe zwar noch gut aber ich habe trotzdem gerne die schriftgröße ein
bisschen größer
ja
hier war mal hier groß advanced wie viel gibt es dann ich also so ultra krass
customizable ist das ist das nicht ja das kenne ich das kenne ich
windows 93 also das ist windows was war das windows 8 90 im browser oder so
oder okay ist ein bisschen größer so schockt mich jetzt nicht großartig das
haben wir uns angeguckt das ist das winnows panel das kennen wir auch
ach guck mal man kann das alte start mit das alte control panel das neue aufmachen
gut das kann über startmenü auch das war es mehr gibt es nicht na das hat mich
jetzt was ist denn der app crapper
was soll denn das sein in mein programmenü wo ist denn mein programmenü
überhaupt programmenü wo ist ja mein program ach hier das da aber angeblich
sollten da schon sachen drin sein ok enden wir mal keine ahnung enden wir
mal irgendwas irgendwas dazu den microsoft store den wollte schon immer mal
geerdet haben continue finish also ja aber das ist das ist das ist wirklich
extrem old school die oberfläche und und also ich weiß nicht also ich ich bin kein
großer fan der das windows desktop so wirklich aber das gefällt mir nicht
windows transformation packs ist es eine gute frage ob es den kram noch gibt
früher gab es ja da viele sachen aber ich glaube ich glaube diese theming
engine ist in windows gar nicht mehr drinne
du könntest auch mal den linux desktop über wsl und x auf das muss ich gar
nicht probieren das war es habe ich schon probiert das läuft nicht ordentlich
das ist dafür gut mal was kurz was was was zu starten wenn man unbedingt was
braucht aber damit arbeiten kann man nicht also das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen
enttäuscht wirklich sinnvoll ist da nichts dabei und vor allem muss man sagen
so laut das jetzt klingt die funktion in windows selber sind irgendwie fast noch
schlüssiger als als das was hier drinne ist das gefällt mir nicht
weg snapshot restore jetzt zeigt noch den raffel zu spät jetzt vorbei was macht ihr
dafür dinger im chat also das war schon mal nix das hat mir überhaupt nicht
gefallen das war mal weg das war nix so als nächstes probieren wir den tiling
den tiling window manager aus das ist irgendein auto in script aber wohl
ziemlich beliebt ich meine es hat 2000 sterne auf github 2000 sterne auf github
ist ordentlich probieren wir probieren wir den kram aus ich meine ihr wisst ja
ich bin großer fan von tiling window manager aber unter windows habe ich mir
da bisher schwer getan das erleben wir den kram mal wie installiert man das
überhaupt wie installiert man das
download stable version or download current development version ok gut machen
wir save as
das ist der source code ich will doch nicht den source code aber ich will das
einfach ausführen wir sind doch unter windows wir sind doch wir sind doch
unter windows
alter warum basteln die immer in ihre in ihre eigentliche backgroundmusik tracks
irgendwelche sprachdinger rein immer weg
der ist no installation process ja aber wie starte ich es denn
ja du solltest es wie es ist oder das
script das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal autohotkey installieren oder wie das
gefällt mir schon mal nicht
ok also extrakten wir das mal
ok run and run and kamann ist nicht
du will have a zip file including execute boogen punkt exe wo
ich habe keine
habe ich stimmlich
angeblich ist da eine exe drin zum ausführen ist nicht
jebaited ok dann downloaden wir mal stable wir
download mal ein stable vielleicht vielleicht geht das ja auch stable ist von mitte 2019
dabei ne ne das ist der github source code ja oh monka ist da ist die exe ok
virus
man weiß es nie aber wir sind in der vm sollte sich in grenzen halten
ok und was was kann man damit jetzt machen
wie sind wir sind an die standard das ist wieder ein read me of doom
wie sind dann die sind an die standard hotkeys
was das verwirrt mich was
gg das gut ok wir starten jetzt einfach mal
oh je geht schon los leute
oh da hat die e3 mappings der hat leute der hat die e3 der hat die e3
tasten mappings drinnen ich kann das jetzt nehmen und einfach
ha ha na ok das tiling ist nicht so ganz nicht so ganz vom feinsten was er hier fabriziert
oh oh yes sieht aber etwas ruckelig aus das können an der vm liegen und wie starte ich
jetzt mal nach so hierher
wo ist man wie waldi hin what ok leute es funktioniert nicht richtig
das funktioniert nicht richtig ich starte in explorer und mein browser ist weg
oh jetzt ist er wie what the fuck what ok ich mach ich mach den wie waldi mal zu ich
glaube der mag den nicht
das funktioniert nicht richtig das ist kaputt
kaputt ok probieren wir mal den explorer aus fullscreen passt
der teilt das nicht oder ich dachte man kann das hier anordnen lassen
wow was das null das ist mir zu big brain wie das funktioniert
alles wird so hoch das ist mir das ist mir echt so hoch das
verstehe nicht das sind meine anwendungen weg das ist mir zu hoch
ich meine er hat bei mir pluspunkte gewinnt sind dadurch gewonnen
einmal eins bedeutet einmal eins ist alles im fullscreen null was ist denn dieser fisch
ich würde jetzt erwarten wenn ich den explorer starte und danach sagen wir
mal in edge dann würde ich erwarten dass der das teilt wenn ich noch ein
explorer starte würde ich erwarten dass es links und rechts ist und wenn ich
jetzt eine cmd starte ich erwarte was was zum geier passiert da überhaupt
so one node starten mal gucken ne das funktioniert nicht richtig das
funktioniert nicht richtig das ist ja müll
guckt eigentlich sollte er das jetzt irgendwie teilen und wirklich und hier
unten drunter guckt noch der explorer aus der explorer wurde geteilt aber
die waldi ist fullscreen ne ne ne das ist das ist müll
das näh näh wirklich wie komme ich hier wieder raus wie beendet man den
spaß denn wieder ich weiß wie
so ne das ist ja enttäuschend bis jetzt das ist ja echt das ist ja echt enttäuschend
dann gucken wir mal wenigstens ob ob die open shell was taugt da hab ich da bin ich
aber sehr sehr zuversichtlich dass open shell was taugt weil das ist der
nachfolger von von der klassik shell die nicht mehr weiterentwickelt wird und die
klassik shell war zu wenig aus acht zeiten so die rettung für alle die
nennt die keine bock auf kacheln hatten
weiter wir gucken mal kurz nach was meine heizung macht
es macht meine heizung so meine heizung temperatur nimmt wieder ab der brenner
brennt ab und zu und die pumpe pumpt ab und zu das abgas ist wieder runter
gegangen ich muss das mal einem heizungs mann
zeigen reborn reborn auf klassik shell
das soll es nicht eher rebirth oder so heißen reborn auf klassik shell
klingt irgendwie ein bisschen verkehrt aber wer bin ich schon mit einem krassen
hessischen englisch
so dann downloaden wir das latest nightly build, ja yolo
gibt es hier vielleicht auch releases die man so
latest nightly build vor fünf monaten
warum ist das latest nightly build älter als das letzte release
ne oder auch nicht 17 days ago ach expires in fünf monaten
keck wait expires das ist das ist tatsächlich aktuell ok
saveen wir einmal das und wir laden uns das letzte release noch mal runter wir
probieren erst mal das letzte wir putt das letzte echte release probieren wir
jetzt mal aus
next excellent next klassik ie ich will eigentlich gar nicht verwenden ehrlich
gesagt classic explorer adds a tool bar to windows explorer place the copier
wir installieren einfach alles next yes
finish
ah guck mal es hat schon hat schon ersetzt jetzt können wir einstellen was
wir haben wollen replace start button ja das ist doch
viel schicker diese komische shell ist doch viel
nicer als das windows ding aber das das gefällt mir schon mal classic das sieht
hässlich aus der classic custom oh leute custom image das das müssen wir jetzt
machen pick image png also
null
wir brauchen das passende startmenu bild
transparent das sein das ist das optimale startmenu bild leute der
wendler nein das bild ist ein bisschen groß ok wir nehmen ein bisschen was
kleineres symbol das nehmen wir das ist gut
oder das das ist schon das schon fast so groß
safe picture das passt nicht das verschiebt sich ist es kaputt also
custom images wohl nicht so gut dann nehmen wir die normale shell wir können
auch keck weh nehmen weil keck weh ist ist viereckiger quadrat ich habe echt
weh
wir gehen einfach mal auf ffz keck weh
das ist das ist auch die optik high dpi die pia ist auch die optimale größe
safe picture die optimale größe für den startbildschirm
eiken keck weh alter das funktioniert nicht warum ist das so kaputt
hier nehmen wir größeres wir nehmen das da hallo warum geht mein rechtsklick
nicht was habe ich da überhaupt gerade geöffnet was ist das windows ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich das wie ich das geöffnet habe das da bing die folgen
ach so wie ich habe auch edge auf ich hätte mal besser die waldi aufmachen
soll hallo seite öffnen please waiting for response das weiß dass die seite
darf ich nicht mal aufmachen ah jetzt ok dann nehmen wir jetzt das
bild safe picture
es funktioniert nicht funktioniert nicht
kann das sein dass der immer dass der immer die obere hälfte nimmt der nimmt
der nimmt die obere hälfte für inaktiv der nimmt die mitte für hover und dann
nimmt klick das untere das heißt man muss sich das extra
anfertigen man müsste sich ein bild anfertigen was quasi dreimal das bild
enthält also ja komm dann nehmen wir das eigentlich ganz lustig ist oder
wir kommen wir nehmen mal wir nehmen mal die schell gut
ließ meine letzte nachricht crochet ist eine letzte nachricht
wetlands button options
oder spark
Buttonsize, was schreibt man da rein? 20?
Oh.
Wie kommt man jetzt wieder in die Settings rein?
Oh ne, wie kommt man wieder in die Settings rein?
Classic Shell.
Best Classic.
Fuck, wie kommt man wieder in die Settings?
Der A hier.
Wir bleiben mal dabei.
Das ist mir zu entwanzern.
Ok, also was können wir da sonst noch auswählen?
Select Style auf Start Menu.
Windows 7 Style ist das, ok.
Ja, das ist eindeutig der Windows 7 Style.
Der ist in der Tat nicht schlecht.
Skin.
Ah.
Metallic?
Classic?
Windows 2000 lässt grüßen, Alter.
Windows 2000 lässt grüßen.
Metro?
Das ist das halbwegs aktuelle.
Midnight?
Passt irgendwie nicht so richtig zusammen, ne?
Windows 8?
Windows 8, so blöd sich's anhört, Windows 8 passt von den Farben und den Sachen her
am besten noch in Windows 10.
Windows Aero.
Auch ok.
No Skin.
Metro war Default, ne?
Ok was kommen wir denn sonst noch mal?
Windows 7 Classic mit 2?
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Oh, das ist aber richtig oldschool jetzt.
Das ist jetzt aber mal hardcore oldschool.
Es ist aber schön schnell, muss man sagen.
Es fühlt sich wirklich schön schnell an.
Hier tracken troppen kann man das nicht.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal so, gar nicht mal so blöd.
Ah, es fühlt sich, es fühlt sich doch ein bisschen zäh an.
Aber so schlecht ist das gar nicht mal.
Allerdings das fühlt sich schon ein bisschen zäh an.
Dann machen wir mal lieber Windows 7 Style.
Der fühlt sich deutlich flüssiger an.
Der ruckelt, der ruckelt.
Also, das beste was wir machen können ist Windows 7 Style.
Der Rest ruckelt rum.
Das hier ruckelt nicht.
Ist das weiterhin die schlechte Suche?
Ich denke mal das ist gar keine Suche, sondern nur intern im Startmenü.
Oh doch, Files, das wird die Windows Suche sein denke ich.
Ich denke das wird die Windows Suche sein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie eine eigene Desktop Suche irgendwie implementiert haben.
Okay, man kann wieder ordentlich tracken troppen.
Ich finde das gar nicht mal schlecht.
Ich finde das wirklich nicht übel was sie hier gebastelt haben.
Ah, das Windows Startmenü kann man auch aufmachen, falls man irgendwas nicht findet.
Das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
So, der beste Skin war tatsächlich, finde ich bisher, Windows 8.
Allerdings nervt mich das weiße, das finde ich so schon besser.
So, was kann man da sonst noch alles einstellen?
Zeig mal her, was haben wir da für Optionen?
Meins sieht so aus, zeig mal her.
Oh, Darksteam, beste.
So schaut es bei ihm aus, das ist tatsächlich ganz nett.
Erstmal das ganze JetBrains Zeug am Start.
Large font, genau, das ist wichtig, das brauchen wir, large font.
Ist das jetzt Durchsichtiger?
Ich glaube das Durchsichtige funktioniert bei mir nicht.
Na doch, ein bisschen, ein bisschen durch, das Durchsichtige wird in der VM nicht ordentlich
funktionieren.
Ah, ja ohne, was, ohne Frames ist besser, mit Frames sieht es kacke aus, ohne Frames
ist besser.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so übel.
So, was kann man da sonst noch hier alles einstellen?
Einfach mal im Schnellverfahren gucken, Controls, okay ganz viel Gedöns, noch mehr Gedöns,
das muss man sich, das werde ich mir jetzt nicht alles im Detail angucken, das ist ja
mega Resident Sleeper, aber ich finde es schon mal gut, dass es sehr customizable ist.
Aha, User Picture, ich habe kein User Picture eingestellt, weil ich ein Local Account bin
und bei Microsoft darf man bei einem Local Account wahrscheinlich kein Bild mehr hinterlegen.
Oh, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, oh das ist cool, dass man sogar sagen könnte,
man möchte das nicht haben, das finde ich ist eine gute Option, Menu Delay, wo hast
du denn das gesehen?
Ah, das ist, wenn man hier drüber geht, wie lange es dauert bis das Untermenü aufgeht,
das ist aber eigentlich ganz gut, dass es ein gewisses Delay hat, weil ansonsten ist
es ja permanent am rumflickern, wenn man da drüber geht, das finde ich, das finde ich
ganz gut.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes, Main Menü, Search Box, Menü Look, Skin,
Image, Sounds, Context Menü, Taskbar, Customize Taskbar, was?
Ahja, gut, das kann ich für das auch mal, ich muss euch sagen, mir gefällt das, das
hat irgendwie was, ich habe mich jetzt allerdings net 1, kann man jetzt auch sagen, Explorer
öffnen, ah, cool, net 1, das ist so eine typische Microsoft Benahmung, weil es net
schon gab, gibt es net 1, wobei ich sagen muss, so cool das sein mag an Features und
sowas, das normale Windows 10 Startmenü tut es irgendwie auch, wobei, ich finde es deutlich
besser als das andere, was wir da ausprobiert haben, ich meine, es ist nur ein Startmenü,
aber dafür ist es halt ein ordentliches, Multi F 101, 2 Monate, Dankeschön, so, die haben
noch ein bisschen mehr dabei, die haben angeblich noch extra Explorer, wir müssen uns den Internet
Explorer angucken, der hat angeblich auch irgendwas eingebaut, ok, was auch immer,
ich will hier gar nicht weiter, man hat jetzt komische Icons hier oben im Explorer, was
ist das, Folder Options, hä, wozu braucht man das denn, ok, das ist ziemlich unsinnig,
ok, jetzt haben wir den Classic Explorer, ich sehe überhaupt keinen Unterschied, seht
ihr einen Unterschied, ich sehe überhaupt keinen Unterschied, aber wir sind auch unter
Windows, da darf man nicht vergessen, dass wir vielleicht neu starten müssen, wir müssen
bestimmt neu starten dafür, dass das funktioniert, gucken wir mal, Microsoft Bob, so, mal schauen,
ob das jetzt funktioniert, ok, das startet sich automatisch, das ist gut und schlecht
zugleich, wenn es einem gefällt, ist es gut, wenn man es wieder wegkriegen will, ist schlecht,
hä, Leute, ich sehe da überhaupt keinen Unterschied, wenn man unter Linux dieselben Spiele spielen
könnte, wie unter Windows, wäre es nur unter Linux, ja, ich auch, also sollte es wirklich
die Möglichkeit geben, irgendwann mal, die Sachen, die ich unter Windows mache, auch
unter Linux machen zu können, dann würde ich sofort nur noch Linux verwenden, aber gibt
es halt nicht, ok, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, Email Selected Items, das ist aber
gefährlich, weil man das aus Versehen macht, ok, die Explorer Extensions sind jetzt nicht
so huge, die Explorer Extensions brauche ich jetzt nicht wirklich, kann man die Explorer
wieder deinstallieren, Classic EE Settings, ok, dann gucken wir mal, ob wir das entfernen
können, Classic Shell, uninstall, wir können es bloß uninstallen, müssen wir das komplett
löschen, dass man die anderen Sachen wegmachen kann, jetzt ist wieder das normale Windows
cluster, also das Menü an sich fand ich echt nicht schlecht, deinstallieren wir noch mal
die Testversion, bis 2017, ok, also Classic EE wollen wir nicht, Classic Explorer wollen
wir auch nicht, Next, guck mal, da hat sich die Settings gemerkt, das ist doch schon mal
ganz schön, ich kann Copy Pasten, das ist das wichtigste, Recent Items und mein Explorer
sieht wieder normal aus, also von allen Sachen, die wir heute getestet haben, muss man testen,
wie schnell das reagiert, nicht schnell genug, teilweise, ich drücke den Shortcut für den
Explorer, obwohl ich eigentlich das hier machen will, und der Windows, kein Problem, ah doch,
ich bin generell zu schnell gerade beim drücken, ich finde es gut, also das ist echt gut, Search
Internet vor 1, oh ne, wir suchen nicht nach 1, wer weiß was man unter 1 alles findet,
das ist doch nice, also das finde ich ist ein schönes Ding, und schon eine Cute Oberfläche
gefunden, ne alles Müll, ja das Anti-Cheat ist tatsächlich ein Problem, aber auch unter
Proton hast du noch einige Probleme mit den Spielen an sich, also was heißt einige, du
hast umgedreht, du hast eigentlich eher Probleme und einige Sachen, die ganz zufrieden stellen
funktionieren, Power Toys, ne die neuen Power Toys habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, also
die anderen 2 Sachen habe ich jetzt echt enttäuscht, das Ding finde ich ganz nice, wenn man es
braucht, aber wirklich sinnvoll, ich meine ein paar von euch verwenden das doch, warum
verwendet ihr lieber die Classic Shell als das Windows Standard Startmenü, der Carlson
6 Monate in Folge, Big Brain Sub, voll verklickt, Dankeschön für den Sub, plus 1, Gewohnheit
ok, ja weil, also es sieht halt aus wie das Windows 10 Startmenü, äh wie das Windows
7 Startmenü, es verhält sich auch ähnlich wie das Windows Startmenü, es ruckelt auch
wie das Windows 10 Startmenü, es ist halt edgy wenn man nicht Standard verwenden, wenn
du nicht Standard verwenden willst, wie wäre es mit einer Linux VM, wie wäre es mit einer
Linux VM wenn du was richtig ausgefallenes verwenden willst, wir haben heute richtig
viel ausprobiert, guck mal nur 1 Stunde 40 on und schon alles durchprobiert was ich probieren
wollte, ok ich würde sagen wir gehen jetzt auf Snapshot, Restore und löschen den Kram
wieder alles, gut also von dem ganzen Zeug was wir heute ausprobiert haben ist eindeutig
die Classic Shell, also die Open, wie heißt das Ding, Open Windows Shell oder so, Open
Shell Menü, eindeutig das beste gewesen, den anderen Kram kann man voll vergessen,
ja Pepega Spam ist angesagt, also das andere Zeug, also das war, da habe ich mir ein bisschen
was von versprochen nachdem ich das hier gesehen habe, aber es war irgendwie belanglos, ja
also weiß nicht wovor man das verwenden soll, die Konzepte waren auch nicht so ganz schlüssig,
an vielen Stellen hat es auch nicht gut funktioniert, wie zum Beispiel mit den virtuellen Desktops
die gar nicht richtig funktioniert haben, ne das war nix, das hier ist gut gedacht,
backt aber übelst rum und das einzige was funktioniert hat und das macht was wir ausprobieren
ist tatsächlich das da und das ist auch wohl ganz gut, hast du schon mal Vox ausprobiert,
ist du ähnlich wie Rofi, ne hab ich nix ausprobiert, GitHub, was ist das, Vox, der Vox Launcher
for Windows, oh what, 15,7k, boah, das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus, what the fuck, 15,7k
is massive, was für eine Distro würdest du als VM für einen Linux Anfänger empfehlen,
also von denen die wir hier im Stream getestet haben, muss ich sagen hatten wir elementary
und das Deep in China Linux am besten gefallen, allerdings wenn du mit was normalem anfangen
willst, was einfach nur gehen soll und du auch vielen Supporter dazu findest, dann
ist, hat glaube ich gerade einer im Chat auch schon mal geschrieben, dann ist Linux Mint
nicht verkehrt, allerdings wenn du es in der VM betreiben willst kannst du, ich überleg
gerade welches es war, die haben zwei Desktops, die haben, genau wenn du es in der VM benutzen
willst, entweder XFCE oder Mate Desktop, Cinnamon ist in der VM nicht so gut, oder war es umgedreht,
war Mate nicht so gut und Cinnamon gut in der VM, XFCE ist auf jeden Fall das leichtgewichtigste
davon, Zorin hatten wir ausprobiert, ich hatte irgendwann die Schmerzen mit Zorin, irgendwas
hat mir Zorin nicht gefallen, weiß aber nicht mehr was, warum nicht einfach Ubuntu kann
man auch machen, allerdings ist die Ubuntu Standard Installation je nach VM nicht richtig
lauffähig, dadurch dass die 3D Beschleunigung brauchen für Desktop, aber damit kann man
auch nichts falsch machen, ich persönlich schwöre ja auf E3WM, da hat man zwar keine
fancy Effekte, aber es ist saumäßig schnell, weil man sich dran gewöhnt hat, also was
wollten wir jetzt nochmal ausprobieren, den Vox Launcher, oh kann man nicht Copy Pasten
machen, doch, ich hab Enter gedrückt, was war das gerade, E3 war so ein Tiling Ding,
das ist aber gewöhnungsbedürftig, also wenn du jetzt erst anfängst mit, wenn du jetzt
erst damit anfängst, hallo kann die Seite sich mal öffnen, was, ach die Seite gibt's
nicht, na das ist ja toll, ist das Projekt vielleicht Abandoned oder so, ach stimmt
ja das kann sein, ok also Download, wo ist es, Vox Excel, Save, Bam, sollen sie mal machen,
und jetzt, ah das ist so ein Launcher, also da kann ich jetzt sowas machen wie 2 plus
2, oh Big Brain, das ist 4, Quick Muffs, Release 2018, Mint, Mint hat aktuelles, Mint ist von,
äh, kam das raus, kam das raus, ja Ende 2019, ach der Vox Launcher, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
stimmt, von 2018, seitdem gab's nichts neues mehr, ja das ist Fail, ja das ist Fail, Dead,
komplett Dead, und die Seite, die Seite ist auch Dead, dabei hat das Projekt schon einiges
halb gehabt mit 15,7 Sternen, äh 7000 Sternen, 15700 Sternen, so wenn man das startet, der
startet ewig lange ne, ach ne, äh, jetzt ist er kaputt Leute, wir haben ihn zerstört,
eben ging er noch, jetzt ist er weg, ah da ist er, Settings, kann man da den Hotkey einstellen
mit was er launcht, Hotkey, was ist, was ist der Hotkey dafür, Alt Space, ah, ok, wow,
ok, hübsch, hübsch ist was anderes, ich muss mir mal angucken was das programmiert
ist, ich hoffe nicht Electron oder irgendwie sowas, man weiß ja heutzutage nie, ah ne WPF
anscheinend oder UWP, aber ich finde ganz ehrlich diese Input Box, die sieht übelst
nach einem Input Feld aus dem Browser aus, oder findet ihr nicht auch, das sieht übelst
nach einem Browser Input Feld aus, ok, also was, was kann man da jetzt machen zum Beispiel
ein schönes, sagen wir mal, wie weit die starten, aber wo ist der Vorteil davon gegenüber
einem Startmenü, ich mein ok, da kann er wahrscheinlich noch mehr, zeig mal was ist
da standardmäßig, was ist da standardmäßig für Plugins drinnen, was, was kann der standardmäßig
alles, Timania, Moin, der Calculator, 2 plus 2 ist 4, minus 1 hat 3 quickmuffs, das können
wir im Calc, das können wir hier drinnen machen, 2 plus 2 minus 1, jawoll, Colors, ok,
das heißt ich kann jetzt mal sagen, XFFF, ah ok, das ist ganz nice, wäre cool wenn
ich so einen Colour Picker hätte, Control Panel, Everything, was, Search on Disk Files
using Everything, Everything ist bestimmt ein eigenes Search Tool oder, das kenne ich,
kenne ich nicht, ah hier, das ist hier ein eigenes, eigenes Search Tool für Windows,
kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert, Folder suchen, Plugins, Programme, Shell Kommandos,
Url, das heißt ich kann auch so was hier machen, wie google.de, ok, das ist tatsächlich,
das ist wirklich recht praktisch, warum gibt es da keine neue Version von, warum ist die
letzte Version von 2008, das ist doch kacke, Web Search, also kann ich auch so was machen
wie hier, ne, da kann ich nicht, ich muss machen G, ok, das ist auch ok, doch das habe
ich, klar habe ich das mal ausprobiert, das habe ich schon vor Jahren mal ausprobiert,
jetzt mit der Suche, jetzt wo ich das sehe, mit der Suche, jetzt fällt mir das wieder
ein, genau, da hat mich damals schon genervt, dass man nicht irgendwas eintippen kann und
dann Enter drücken kann und dann sucht da Google, jaja, hat das Auto Complete, hat
das Auto Complete, gibt es ein offizielles Plugin Depot, das ist dead, das ist richtig
dead, probieren wir es mal aus, everything void tools, ist ja nur vm, kann ja nicht viel
schief gehen, also die Seite ist dead, du kannst Suggestions anmachen, Save Knopf gibt es
nicht, ok, das heißt wenn ich jetzt danach suche, nach Max, haha, gebated, oder hat er
das jetzt nicht übernommen, ne, die Suggestions kommen wahrscheinlich erst wenn ich mache
ein Geh, ne, Geh, hallo, Geh, ah, yes, Geh, ahja, guck mal da ist er, da ist er, ok,
download Installer, dann lassen wir mal unsere Platte indizieren, gucken was das macht, wäre
es nicht schön wenn es in Windows einen offiziellen Paketmanager gäbe, raffunkeldunkel, ja und
ich liebe natürlich den Chat, was sonst, jetzt gleich erstmal den Scamtrain auf 100% prügeln,
benutzt du, was nutzt du als Stromversorgung für den ESP8266, alles wo ein USB Stecker
dran ist, das Ding braucht ja nichts, ich hab einige Steckdosen, die haben direkt USB mit
dabei, ja aber das ist nichts offizielles, ich mein sowas richtig offizielles, Paketmanager,
ja, ja klar, wenn das irgendwie ein Team aus Freiwilligen machen kann, dann kann das Microsoft
auch machen, ja, ich mein die müssten es nicht unbedingt hosten, aber die müssten
das Ding verifizieren, den ESP Autark ohne Steckdose, mit Batterie, mit Batterie ist die
Herausforderung, du brauchst erstmal das richtige Board dafür, also was ich dir empfehlen kann
als ESP32, beim ESP8266 bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, ESP32, wenn du es wirklich an
der Batterie betreiben willst, ist der hier gut, der ist halt ein bisschen teurer, aber
der hat so gut wie keinen Stromverbrauch wenn er im Deep Sleep ist, das Board, das hat auch
den gleichen Batterie Connector dran, und dann nimmst du so eine kleine Batterie, sowas
da und stöpselst, sowas da, nimmst du, da hab ich zwei Stück von, von den Firepeatle
ESP32, normale ESP32 Boards verbrauchen zu viel, weil die haben ja einen USB dran, und
die Dinger sind so noob, noob styleig gemacht vom Hersteller, dass die auch im Batteriebetrieb
dann den, den USB Anschluss, den Strom versorgen und sowas, die brauchen zu viel, der Firepeatle
braucht wirklich nichts, also so gut wie nichts, der braucht, der braucht glaube ich 10, 10
Mikro Ampere oder so, im Deep Sleep, da Funkeldunkel, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Dankeschön
für den Sub, als Erstes nehmen wir das mal, ich hab, Systema hat probiert mal richtig
viel Windows-Gedöns aus, was ich sonst natürlich nicht mache, weil mich zumindest was am Arsch
vorbeigeht, was man so ein Windows in der Richtung machen kann, ok, immer installen,
yes, excellent, Run, und jetzt indiziert er so vor sich hin, Search, na gut auf der Festplatte
ist ja nicht viel drauf, das ist sowas wie Locate für Linux, das erscheint, das sieht
für mich aus wie ein bisschen, bisschen wie was, wie Locate im Endeffekt, einfach ein
kleiner Index über die, weil man kann auch kein Inhalt suchen, einfach ein Index über
die Dateienamen, richtig interessant wird es ja bei Indizierung vom Inhalt her, kann
er auch Inhalt suchen, kann er auch Inhalt suchen, ne oder, Blob, Blob, ne Inhalt kann
er nicht suchen, den Inhalt kann er nicht indizieren, ne, Inhalt, Inhalt indiziert
er nicht, ok, das heißt jetzt kann ich aber Files da drüber suchen, Blob, ah, ok, das
ist tatsächlich ganz cool, das gefällt mir gut, Microsoft wollte doch mal vor 10 Jahren,
Dings, Next, Next-Ged oder so sollte das heißen, das haben sie nicht gebacken gekriegt, da
hab ich schon ein Video damals drüber gemacht, wo gibt es denn aktuelle Builds von diesem
anderen Tool hier, weil ich mein 2008 ist halt schon, Build und Build, gibts halt, ist
halt ein bisschen alt oder, ich mein will der nicht mal ein neues Release machen, 2008,
die PC ist sehr alt, das ist ein Jahr, ein Jahr hinten dran, ob die Leute sich schon
beschweren, New Release, hat auch einer gepostet, ok, irgendein Typ kompiliert das selbst, aber
das ist jetzt halt wieder auch so was Inoffizielles, ne, das scheint mir so ein Ding zu sein was
so halbsupported ist, äh 2018 mein ich, ja ihr wisst doch, dass ich manchmal komische,
wenn ich mich nicht drauf konzentriere, was ich sage, dann kanns sein, dass wenn ich abgelenkt
bin manchmal komisches Zeug erzähle, an sich finde ich das von den Funktionen her aber
ziemlich nice, muss ich mal sagen, das hat was, ich mein der riesen Vorteil zum Startmenü,
zum Launcen von Anwendungen erschließt sich mir jetzt noch nicht, aber das kommt wahrscheinlich
erst dann, wenn man die Details verwendet, die Sache ist die, ich glaube das Produkt
ist ziemlich, ziemlich tot, weil die offizielle Seite geht halt nicht mehr und in der Regel
ist wenn die offizielle Seite von einem Produkt tot ist, ist meistens kein gutes, kein gutes
Zeichen, was gibt, gibt es da eine Übersicht mit Plugins, da gibt es wirklich 30 Milliarden
Sachen, ne Puttysession, oh das ist für alle Windows Leute natürlich super, wie Rofi für
Windows, ja aber Rofi gefällt mir viel besser, benutzt ja Rofi auch nur als Launcher, die
ganzen Zusatzfunktionen, die Fenster suchen, ich hab ja eben gut, ich hab ja keine Fenster
und irgendwelche special Sachen, mach ich nicht, ähm, es gibt ja zu Rofi, wie heißt
die Rofi Alternative nochmal, da gab es doch letztens was, hab ich gesehen, da gab es
doch letztens was gut, New Launcher, ne, ne, ne, ne, Rofi Clipboard, da hab ich mir was
eigenes gestrickt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es da jetzt was offizielles gibt.
Wayland, wer ist, wer ist so lebensmüde und verwendet, verwendet Wayland, oh, Rofi, um
mich zu holen, Green Clip, was war das hier, Highskill, what the, Highskill, Monkeys, ich
find das Ding aber wirklich, doch, doch, ich muss sagen, das ist ganz nützlich, das ist
tatsächlich ganz, ganz praktisch, vor allem mit dem Indizieren von, ähm, was, wo kommt
das her, oh, das ist irgendwas von Windows, ok, ähm, vor allem mit dem, mit dem Integrieren
von, von der Windows-Suche finde ich das wirklich ganz praktisch, äh, die Frage der Fragen,
die wir natürlich klären müssen, ist, ist das in meinem Paketmanager drinnen, Vox, ja,
suchen please, ok, ist drinnen, das find ich gut, ok, war das, war das auch das aktuelle
Release, oder ist das schon was Neues, was die drinnen haben, 1, 3, 5, 7, 8, oh nee,
das ist ja noch älter, das ist ja noch älter, was da im Repo drinnen ist, halt, da, da sieht
man halt wieder, was das Problem ist, dass Windows kein Dateimanager hat, das ist von
Februar 2018, da sieht man halt wieder, was das Problem ist, dass Windows kein Dateimanager
hat, natürlich kann das von der Community gemacht werden, bzw. von irgendwelchen, ähm,
einzelnen Kriegern gemacht werden, aber unterm Strich ist halt die Pflege der Sachen hinüber,
sobald die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben, was war das latest stable, ach, tatsächlich, ich
hab nix gesagt, aber trotzdem, stimmt ja, was ich gesagt hab, ähm, ist ja nicht verkehrt,
deswegen, es wär, es wär echt was Nicest für Windows, wenn die mal es schaffen würden,
offiziell einen Paketmanager bereitzustellen, und der halt, und nicht der Windows Store,
alter, niemand vertreibt seine Software, der noch mal Sinn ist über den Windows Store,
ähm, äh, Kenmore weiß jetzt nicht genau, was das spezifisch, also das einzige, was
ich bisher mal gemacht habe, so mit UI-Automatisierung, ist, ähm, Puppetier, diese Chrome-Fernsteuerung,
kannst du kurz mal Git erklären, kurz, äh, kurz geht das nicht, ok, und dann wollt ich
auch gucken, ob diese Search drinne ist, nee, Everything ist das, hab ich verguckt, Bräutools
war der Hersteller, oder, Everything ist, auf Search, ah, ok, also die Kombination, muss
ich sagen, finde ich ganz brauchbar, die Kombination finde ich wirklich ganz nice, ah, Paint, bam,
keiner startet da drüber, Paint, aber, äh, dass man direkt ne Google-Suche machen kann,
oh, what the fuck, so direkt ne Google-Suche machen kann, finde ich sehr gut, ähm, dass
die Suggestions macht, finde ich nice, wenn du sowas für Linux, ich brauch das nicht
für Linux, hab, ich hab alles für Linux in der Richtung schon, brauch eher was ordentliches
für Windows, aber U-Launcher wird überhaupt nicht mehr weiterverwickelt, oder, oder ist
es jetzt was, ach nee, das ist was Neues, U-Launcher, das hab ich noch, das hab ich
noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich muss, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich bin da, äh, ich
starte da drüber eh nur Programme, die ganzen Fernsehsachen mach ich da drüber gar nicht,
Max Mac OS oder Windows, was findest du besser, boah, in welchem Bereich, in welchem Bereich,
ähm, letztendlich, müsste ich, so, wenn ich spontan antworten müsste, würde ich sagen,
ganz klar Mac, weil, ähm, du zumindest ne ganz gute Chance hast, ne ordentliche Programmierumgebung
und ne Unix-artige, Linux-artige Umgebung unter Mac hinzubekommen, ähm, du hast ne ordentliche
Shell, du hast ein ordentliches Terminal, Iterm 2 finde ich fast noch nen Ticken besser,
als die Sachen, die es unter Linux gibt, ähm, und, aber unterm Strich kommt es ja drauf an,
was man für Anwendungen braucht, und da bist du halt unter Windows von der Auswahl her
immer noch besser aufgehoben, es gibt die ein oder andere, es gibt schöne Anwendungen
für Mac, die es nicht unter, unter Windows gibt, zum Beispiel hätte ich mir vor Jahren
mal gerne ne Omni-Crawler-Version für Windows gewünscht, das ist so ein Visio, das war
noch die Zeit, als ich sowas wie, ähm, sowas wie Visio verwendet habe, und das ist halt
unter, unter Mac ist das viel angenehmer als dieser Windows, als dieser Windows Visio-Geschiss
da.
Everything mit der Instant-Indizierung auf Linux, hab ich noch nie geguckt, was es gibt,
ehrlich gesagt.
Also integriert, integriert wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nix, aber
der Profi ist ziemlich erweiterbar, also wenn man ein ordentliches Index-Tool unter Linux
hat, kann man das, denke ich, auch ganz gut integrieren.
Welchen Stuhl benutzt du fürs 10 plus Stunden, den hier, den hier, der da, bester Stuhl,
Leute, der beste Stuhl, den ich je benutzt hab, ich krieg dafür kein Geld.
Hast du dir schon mal Schokolati angeguckt, ja hab ich vor ner ganzen Weile, ähm, in
letzter Zeit nicht mehr, ähm, ich verwende für, ich verwende eigentlich nur noch Scoop
für meine Entwicklungssachen, ähm, das ist allerdings nicht systemweit, sondern nur lokal
bei mir im Benutzerverzeichnis und das reicht mir.
Was mir bei Schokolatis letztes Mal überhaupt nicht gefallen hat, war die Oberfläche und
auch dieses im Hintergrund rumgewurstete Ding mit den PowerShell Skrippen, die teilweise
nicht richtig gelaufen sind.
Da muss man halt sagen, da ist Linux mit einem ordentlichen Paketmanager wirklich meilenweit
vorne.
Und die Premium-Lösung ist natürlich ein ordentlicher Paketmanager plus User-Repos,
wie das unter Archlinux ist.
Das finde ich ist immer noch top, ähm, genau, da muss man halt gucken, da muss man halt
gucken, dass man den für einen ordentlichen Preis kriegt.
1800 Euro ist definitiv, definitiv zu viel, ähm, wenn man ein bisschen rumguckt und ein
bisschen, ein bisschen nachschaut, kriegt man den schon eine ganze Ecke günstiger,
also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man die Möglichkeit hat, den Stuhl für
eine ganze Ecke unter 1000 Euro zu finden, wenn man ein bisschen schaut.
Das ist übrigens genau die Konfig, die ich bei mir stehen habe hier.
Beim Büro, Götz, äh, das ist genau die Konfig, die ich hier bei mir stehen habe.
Sag mal, warum kann man das Bild nicht groß machen, hier ist das Bild doch auch viel größer.
Lul.
Kegwe.
Das ist ein komischer Shop, der nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ähm, das ist genau die Konfig, die ich hier auch bei mir stehen habe, mit dieser Kopfstütze.
Die ist mir allerdings nicht, nicht groß genug, die, die Kopfstütze, die Kopfstütze.
Ähm, ich hab da noch so ein extra, noch so ein kleines Kisschen dran, mit so einem,
mit so einem Gummiband oben, was extra für so Stühle gemacht ist.
Ähm, aber der Stuhl ist halt echt gut.
Wie gesagt, ihr erinnert euch ja noch dran, im letzten Stream, wo ich das mit der Bluetooth-Wage
ausprobiert hab, das heißt, ihr wisst, was ich wiege.
Ähm, es ist übrigens wieder ein bisschen weniger geworden, noch weniger als beim letzten,
beim letzten Stream.
Äh, seid froh, dass ich den Stream nicht an Weihnachten gemacht hab, ähm, und, also
wenn ich mich hier, wenn ich mich hier draufschmeiße, auf den Stuhl hier, bäm, der federt, aber
da wackelt nix, macht nix, also das ist, der ist auch Kokona-tauglich, ja.
Hast du keinen Max-400-Euro-Stuhl?
Ich hatte, ich hatte davor einen DX-Racer-Stuhl, der war eine ganze Ecke günstiger als 400
Euro, aber der war kacke.
Ich hatte den Auswahl danach, kauf ich mir noch mal so ein halbes Ding, oder kauf ich
mir den, und ich hab mir den gekauft.
Mit dem Preis kriegt man auch einen Hermann Miller Premium in Office-Stühlen, was ergonomisch,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die besser sind als die.
Das ist der beste Stuhl, auf dem ich je gesessen hab.
Und das ist jetzt wirklich keine Übertreibung, ich krieg auch kein Geld von denen.
Ich hab viele Stühle ausprobiert, weil wir hatten auf der Arbeit mal ne richtige Probierwelle
an Stühlen, was die kaufen sollen, ich hab massig Stühle ausprobiert und nichts gegenüber
diesen Stuhl.
Also empfohlen, mag sein, dass das auch gute Stühle sind, aber der ist für mich der absolut
beste Stuhl.
Gibt für mich nix besseres.
Zeig mir mal einen, der empfohlen wird auf Reddit, ich will das mal vergleichen.
Hast du den auch in der Arbeit?
Ja, den haben wir auch auf der Arbeit.
Das heißt, ich sitze im Prinzip am Tag, ich sitze den gesamten Tag in diesem Stuhl.
Ich sitze auf der Arbeit in diesem Stuhl und ich sitze daheim in diesem Stuhl.
Und ich muss schon überzeugt sein von einem Stuhl, dass ich 1000 Euro für einen Stuhl
ausgebe.
Der DX Racer Stuhl ist jetzt, no witz, auseinandergebrochen.
Am Rahmen auseinandergebrochen, alter.
Und das, und das nach knapp einem Jahr.
Was hältst du von Backforce One?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was, was, Backforce One, hört sich nach Gaming RGB Stuhl an.
Pro Equipment für echt, nein.
Das sieht nicht wie was aus, was ich mir kaufen würde.
Außerdem leckt die Webseite extrem.
Nee, nee, da hab ich, hab ich instinktive Abneigung dagegen, wenn ich das sehe.
Ich kann euch nicht genau sagen, was, aber da hab ich instinktive Abneigung dagegen.
Wo hast du den Seedos Stuhl gekauft, das weiß ich nicht mehr, das ist zu lang her.
Medi-Kriticaler, sag mir mal ein, nach dem ich gucken soll.
Sag mir mal ein Stuhl, nach dem ich gucken soll.
Ah, Aeron, okay.
Hier ist die Miller.
Ah, Aeron.
Okay, da ist auch, wat?
What the fuck?
Das hat überhaupt kein richtiges Polster am Rücken.
Das sieht nicht bequem aus.
Jetzt ernsthaft, also ich will, ich will es nicht auf Teufelkommen raus nieder machen,
aber du hast ja da einfach nur ein paar Stofflappen am Rücken.
Den Backforce hat der Inscope 21 und schlägt ihn immer am Anfang seiner Videos vor, denn
Niko wird die Dinger am Anfang seines Videos vorschlagen, weil er dafür Geld kriegt und
weil der Niko wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu viele Stühle ausprobiert hat.
Dafür bist du im Sommer nicht am schwitzen.
Ach gut, bin ich auch so nicht bei meiner Klimaanlage.
Belegtes Brot, abonniert Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, huge.
Okay, Embody haben wir da noch.
Ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, also ich kann es jetzt letztendlich nicht beurteilen,
ich habe die Dinger noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich finde nicht, dass die Dinger bequem
am Rücken aussehen.
Ne, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht irgendwie.
Da bleibe ich lieber bei meinem 24-7-Stuhl, also gut, ich bleibe da eh dabei, weil 1000
Euro Stuhl schmeißt man die einfach weg und das Ding kann ich auch nix zu sagen, wie gesagt
nicht ausprobiert, aber da habe ich von der ganzen Aufmachung her schon ein ziemlich schlechtes
Gefühl bei.
Das ist hier, was ich gerade gelesen habe, ich habe hier gerade gelesen, du zockst die
ganze Nacht, Backforce kümmert sich um deine Blase, ich habe gedacht, da ist irgendwie
ein Pissbeutel eingebaut oder so, das wäre doch mal was oder, Backforce kümmert sich
um deine Blase, Dual-Core-Sitz, echter Sport, die Seite ruckelt, der von, was eigentlich
ein Pissbeutel ist, das ist ein Pissbeutel, das ist ein Pissbeutel, das ist ein Pissbeutel,
da ist ein Pissbeutel, das ist ein Pissbeutel, ein Pissbeutel, das ist ein Pissbeutel, das
Die die sachen also das ist wirklich einfach richtig ein eiser stuhl
Was ist hier los? Ah der Bildschirmschoner. Ah yes Bildschirmschoner. Exzellent
Ich erwisch mich manchmal wie ich auf der arbeit so dummes zeug vor mich hin hin laber
Ich hab letztens irgendwas gemacht am laptop von unserem azubi und hab dann hab dann enter gedrückt und hab irgendwie sowas
Irgendwie sowas laut vor mich hin gesagt so nach dem motto. Ah yes exzellent fife hat exzellent
Der hat nichts gesagt
Er hat er hat nichts gesagt aber wahrscheinlich hat er sich gedacht dass der alde total verrückt ist der spinn das macht die leute
fertig im kopf
Ja, man muss nicht unbedingt weltklasse sein um einen stuhl promoten zu können
Macht das auch jedes mal? Ah yes
Hast du eine private? Ja ich habe eine ganz normale workstation lizenz die habe ich vor ein paar jahren an weihnachten
Die haben irgendwie so ein komisches sale an weihnachten immer normalerweise kostet was 140 und an weihnachten kostet irgendwie nur 69
Davon fragen wie alt du bist ich bin 400
Exzellent ich bin 35
Ich bin 1984 geboren ich musste gerade überlegen ich wollte gerade an 34 aber nein es ist 35
Ich bin 1984 geboren ich musste gerade an 34 aber nein es ist 35
Wie viele chrome tabs haben wir doch letztens erst geschaut
Aber das nicht erst letztens geguckt
Okay, dann gucken wir kommen wir gucken uns jetzt noch an wir haben die windows wir haben die windows sachen doch schon ausprobiert
Wir haben im büro dank unseren bussiness was dank unserer neuen
business development managerin was macht man als business development managerin
Ist sie auch agil und ihr auch seid ihr seid ihr alle schön agile
Für agile multilevel speed architekturen
Zeig mal her
Da könnte ich nicht drauf sitzen was ist denn das
Da würde ich mich weigern da tut ihr ja alles weh nach dem halben tag
Das ist so ein stuhl wo ich mir nicht vorstellen der hat ja nicht mal arme lehnen
Wie zum teufel will man den stuhl wie man will man mit dem stuhl arbeiten der keine arme lehnen hat
Soll das wie soll das gehen
Ach man sitzt da so
Rund drauf da komme ich aber gar nicht richtig an die tastatur
Ich bin skeptisch ob das was taugt
Du sollst nicht arbeiten an ergonomisch schützen
Taugt das echt was
Ich will jetzt zwar nicht schlecht reden taugt das jetzt ernsthaft also mein das
Wieso sind die so teuer weil die sein
Interessiert die dicht aktien finanz thema ich
Prinzipiell schon ich muss mich unbedingt mehr mit
Der ganzen sache mal auseinandersetzen weil ich habe so viel kohle einfach sinnlos rumliegen
Bis auf ein paar wenige sachen dass es eher weniger wird und das sagt
Was für ein smartphone hast du
Welches wüsstest du dann gerne
Okay, bleiben wir mal also mein smartphone was ich täglich verwende ist ein iphone xs
Ich habe kein android das kommt von viele immer überraschend
Dafür habe ich jede menge andere android geräte aber was smartphones angeht
Aber was smartphones angeht hat es hat mehrere gründe warum ich ein iphone habe hauptsächlich weil ich es nicht selbst bezahlen muss
Ich kann dir sagen welche unterhosen ich nicht trage ich habe mal den fehler gemacht mir vor einem jahr oder so marken unterhosen zu kaufen
Und jetzt weiß ich auch warum hugo boss nicht umsonst auf dem absteigenden ast ist
Die waren der allerletzte scheiß
Die sind nach einmal waschen kaputt gegangen der gummi
Wirklich nach einmal waschen gummi im arsch
Löcher löcher an zwischendurch
Der allerletzte krab und sogar noch relativ teuer also das werde ich nie wieder kaufen
Gummi im arsch und der chat wieder der chat
Welche grafikkarte hast du ich habe immer noch 1080 ti
Okay, how many chrome tabs can you open
Okay, how many chrome tabs can you open das gucken wir uns noch an
Das gucken wir uns an wir wollten uns das videos letztes mal schon angucken
Reddit finanzen starter kit
Ist das ist das
Empfehlenswert ja
kappa hd
Kappa hd
Max ist in ffm an der quelle und kommt nicht ins stonks game
Aber man muss sich für das stonks game auch interessieren
Und
Moon wie zwei monate dankeschön
Bist du mit deinem single leben zufrieden möchtest du schon mal jemand haben
Oh das thema hatten wir schon öfters
Das das thema hatten wir schon öfters wenn ich wenn ich davon jetzt wieder anfange
Ja prinzipiell schon aber
Ich finde
Wer sich nur erinnert sie nur einer das weihnachtsgrill
von vor zwei Jahren
Ich finde zwischenmenschliche sachen einfach unglaublich anstrengend
Sodass ich mich sodass ich halt alles schleifen lasse ja
Legendär
Ich kümmere mich um zwischenmenschliche beziehung einfach nicht also sprich selbst
Selbst leute die ich eigentlich gern habe und
Den ich auch gerne was machen würde ich kümmere mich da nicht drum
Ich finde zwischenmenschliche beziehung sehr also extrem
Unmotivieren für mich so
Das ist ich weiß dass ich da nicht also ich bin nicht der einzige und ich weiß aber auch dass ich garantiert nicht zu der mehrheit gehöre
Das sehe ich auch immer wie viele leute gerne auf das sommerfest gehen auf die weihnachtsfeier gehen oder sonstige geschichten auf der arbeit machen und
Irgendwelche nach aktivitäten danach oder am wochenlände irgendwelche großartige action machen oder sonst was für mich ist das anstrengend ich mache keine
Zwischen zwischenmenschliche sachen sind für mich
Anstrengend in den wieb spam den wieb spam das erste wenn ich morgens den discord aufmache ich gucke morgens wenn ich auf die
Arbeit komme an discord was die leute wieder so rumgespammt haben das erste was ich mache ist den wieb spam rechts anklicken und sagen als gelesen
Markieren dass ich nicht aus versehen auf die idee komme da rein zu klicken
So wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal das video an das wollten wir uns das letzte mal schon angucken
Max ist autist also ich glaube auf der autismus gala wenn es sowas gäbe bin ich auf jeden fall
In diese richtung aber es fehlt noch einiges dazu
Ja ja so kommen wir uns mal das video an
Würdest du sagen das stream gleich arbeit ist nö
Auf der ppegas gala oder da bin ich ganz schön weit oben
2 terabytes am start ist aber ist aber echt kein ding 2 terabyte wir hatten vor jahren schon surfer mit 2 terabyte vor jahren also sprich dort wo noch kein ddr 4 oder sonst was das war noch
Gut ist es war wirklich lange her da hatten sie quasi 64 g 64 g module drauf und der witz ist wenn man 2 terabyte sieht mit 64 g modulen das sieht enttäuschend aus man denkt jetzt man macht die abdeckung auf von der kiste und das ganze ding ist voller ram und im endeffekt hat es einfach auch nur vorne ein paar ram bänke mehr
Meinung dazu dass jublog origin jetzt die ip adresse auslesen will bzw. ich breche habe ich gesehen habe ich mir keine gedanken zugemacht gibt es dazu irgendwas
Habe ich mir keine gedanken zugemacht
Ja das ist doch sinnvoll
Ja kann man machen warum nicht schadet nix
Okay dann ist es neuer da reichen ja 16 sogar ansonsten hat es halt 32 gebraucht für 64 g module
Der hat den sellout einfach schon im blut
Also ich finde dense gaming macht immer super sellouts eingebunden in seinen let's plays und linux schafft einfach linux schafft die überleitung immer sehr sehr weich zum sellout
Ich bin eigentlich vollkommen wurscht hauptsache das ding hat es
Habe ich mir noch nie gedanken zugemacht